So good.
So yes.
Hello. I am.
Terry mcgee and i mean this nym
and story because i was a participant
of at the original aquarius festival
who stayed on. I came.
A few weeks before the festival
a friend of mine bob craven and
and others were here working
as part of the organisation
and i came up did a bit of help in
the architectural team beforehand
and then this here for the festival.
I suppose the.
My further relevance why i'm still sort
of talking about it is because at the end
of the festival there was one workshop
being chaired by richard neville
and to discuss later. Communities
being formed in the area.
After the festival and
i was at the workshop.
We talk for hours.
Richard neville invited one
particular person to organise some
sort of. After the festival process.
And i guess i had a feeling that
that particular person was not going to
be incredibly successful in doing it
and i simply set about with some
discussions with ken yeomans son of a key
line. Irrigation farmer.
I set about.
Starting to nibble force registering
the cooperative arranging the
deal on the land and then.
Going through the process of
trying to build up an organization
that the cooperative when it was
registered would be the legal.
Part of it.
And i hadn't come with
an intention to stay.
I came with the possibility i mean i didn't
i'd i don't always thought about moving
up to the north coast of new
south wales but i expected that.
Any place
that i would want to would
be right on the coast
and so i hadn't expected to
come up with to decide to do
that. Challenge of.
The challenge that.
I may have a story writer
and one of the stories
that i was writing in and still
haven't finished at that at
that time was the story of a
and a large island where people
were coming in from overseas
sort of almost in their dreams.
To build new communities to.
Get away from various old world problems
and so i just sort of automatically
thought to myself of
that this was part of
the grounding of making
that story a very real very
detailed being able to help on
details of that story.
I also thought that.
Because of the festival.
And some of the people that we're here
that there was the spirit in
terms of an artistic community
one that was interested in a lot of.
A lot of thoughts a lot
of new ideas and that.
This might in fact be a better
such place than one on the coast
that would get distracted by
the the joys of the beach.
It was more the color. The background.
It was almost like a movie
that was a great movie
but they forgot to put
in part of the story.
There was no connecting story and
i felt that at the time i felt
that part of that reason was
that because it had been centered
on the town instead of it.
One of the other options before the festival
was to try to arrange town a bill for
the whole property as the
festival site and if
that would have been the case then the
festival would have there would have been a
story of the building of a new
town creating the starting of.
When new town village but because it was
transitory in that sense of the coming
and going. It.
It was almost. How does crime.
The best way that i thought
of later was to talk.
I had images of some songs
and story of ghosts walking along the
streets of nimbin after the festival
and that there. Here was
this little country town
that had been so incredibly
alive like like a 30
or 40 thousand people village because
all of its not that there were
that many people but all of its residents
were very active they were going out
and so you had this big. Artistic town.
And then it was totally empty
and it was full of ghosts.
Well it sort of like the story
that goes to hell is hard to.
It's hard to actually capture on
film. Because when you shoot it.
You can't see the ghosts and you
can't hear what they're saying
but you see the color.
The ghosts are
but the they haven't made themselves
particularly more visible there.
The.
I don't think
that it's the town itself has moved
a huge distance from its potential.
Its potential is i've
something where there's a.
An artistic economic life
that requires a town.
There's not. That level of of.
Real solid artistic business
that is being done to justify
its existence of the town
its existence as a town is a story
called that there was a town there
that was empty and was not
being used very much.
Because all of its not all but one
half of its residents were pensioners
and so they were just enjoying this
beautiful little town but it wasn't.
It wasn't doing much and it wasn't very
alive it wasn't doing a lot of business
and. The things that could have
occurred during the festival
or straight after the
festival would didn't occur
and haven't occurred yet even
with all this business activity.
You know new shops opening
in town at the moment.
They know they're not touching
anything like that the tension
or for a true arts centre.
Alternative art centre.
Alternative arts capital of
australia or whatever you can go
and choose lots of sort of ways to
describe most likely at the moment.
Byron bay is more of an art centre.
And there's more than there niman anyway.
I think it's more the the whole economic.
The whole week anomic
superstructure the whole sense of
taking. Taking taking the business
side of it all. Seriously.
I guess it's in many ways you get the
feeling of people running around making a
movie but the movie never gets made.
Well the other classic example
is that all fours hall. It's.
Under can stick beautiful structure
and it's it's a really beautiful
really elegant really nicely design
but it's been under
construction for 16 years now.
Something like 16 years. Whereas
over it. So a billion cliffs.
There's been quite a beautiful new
craft center build in three months
and it's completed it's
opening next weekend and
that sort of frustration
at this beautiful hall.
That is is quite stunning
and is the sort of classic
ingredients for a very artistic
but business. Real artistic
as in art that makes money.
Is this whole that would be beautiful part
of that is incomplete. After 15 years.
And the way.
I think it's the different
parts of of life
that the communities been
able to face up to one
or two whole aspects very
very well. Brilliantly.
But haven't gone beyond those
in a organized way if you
look at the whole.
If you look at the the development
of a of a community from scratch
such as at a time before.
And really you can treat the
whole of the nim and valley in
that way because the a number
of people and houses and.
Other things for people to do other than.
Milk cows the level of that
in this valley 20 years ago.
It was a fairly low level there
wasn't a huge amount of of us
develop space
and time to go
when it started got pretty
straight into two parts.
Namely of.
Building houses and growing fruit trees
and real forestation now at that level
taliban has worked brilliantly.
There's a huge number of really
beautiful houses very laid back into
the environment. Very non obtrusive.
A lot of really good fruit trees
and other trees throughout the whole
property the regrowth down in the valley has
been really beautiful and the.
The way that there are so many trees
and the orchards are broken up.
Has really minimized insect. Problems.
But then beyond those two aspects
of the whole tree agricultural
and the housing. The whole other
levels of mechanical economics
and post mechanical economics.
Have have only been at a.
Early stage
and there's been a really
strong argument against
and being dealt with at a community level.
If in the early days of tenable force there
was a strong desire amongst a lot of
people to limit tenable forces.
As activities to housing and tree gardens.
And.
There's there's that sort of kept on
and overridden throughout the whole valley
there's a large fear of development
which amongst not everyone.
Maybe not amongst the majority
but certainly amongst a very
strong number of people
and they feel it very strongly
and they try to put a whole inference
of badness against any economic
activity that is not at their scale and
that ends up with a real real
difficulty a real hard a
hard press.
I suppose you could say it just puts
anyone who's trying to do things
that are not house building
or a tree garden orientated at a major
disadvantage where they have to carry out
a lot of extra trouble a lot of extra
weight in order to do the same job.
Yes it's it's. One of the.
One of the aspects of why
there's it's been difficult to
get our community level planning
on on economics beyond the house
and gardens has been part of the
origins of the festival itself.
In so many people coming up.
And being part of the festival who had a
vietnam protest orientation before they
came. And when you're dealing with.
No tests the name classic
example the key thing
that you're always centering on
is saying no you are constantly
coming up with a million brilliant
arguments and a million.
Brilliant ways og saying no
i'm trying to stop things
and in fact of course when
the terrain your issue.
Blew up up here to
that then double tailed completely into
the ecological question of saying no.
I'm concentrating on stopping things of
learning how to stop things of spending
investing your life's effort
in learning how to say no
and to stop things as a moral good
not only learning it as a skill
but actually investing it with
that is the moral good thing.
And anyone who is not doing.
Learning
and specializing in how to say
no is doing something bad
and that that's been there.
Right for a huge amount of the years
we we had a lot of debates in nimbin
where graham dunstan.
And some other people were trying to argue
that we had to keep the
whole of the valley.
Only working on spontaneous
structures and i argued the case
that it had to be on ongoing structures
that had the capacity for spontaneity
as distinct from demanding
that the structures be
spontaneous structures.
The reality is that for structures
that are going to say no.
That are going to oppose things you
only need a spontaneous structure.
However graeme dunstan's now come back
to town wanting to do a 20 year festival
next year and he is really frustrated
that there's no ongoing structure
that's capable of helping him do that.
It's it's with the.
It just runs with the philosophy
that if people practice it saying no too
often they in fact find it difficult to
understand how difficult it is to get
new things occurring to write a play
to put on a play to do a
musical to start a business.
To do a musical is to start a business.
You can't the the number of people
that you're going to involve the amount
of time that you're going to ask of them.
The amount of extra
materials and resources
that you're going to need is
equal to a small business
and i suppose i've always had
some level of our intention of
that of how difficult getting something
that does not exist to actually exist.
Change direction.
Next. Role.
Beyond it beyond the
houses and three gardens.
Getting other things to occur requires a
and irian tatian but that means
that they have to actually get them self
and other people to agree on
how to do things together.
All business or things
that require 20 30 people tend to work
together involve business transactions
whether it's running a pre-school
or whatever you have to get a number of
people agreeing saying yes to putting in a
lot of effort in order to get a whole
range of things coordinated together.
And that irian tatian
is i suppose something
that alone has taken a fair
while in nimbin we early on it.
Tenable fours gave up the idea of
trying to get a lot of houses built by
a building unit for instance.
That's one of the possibilities
we could have looked at but it.
We weren't going to be able to agree on.
Many of the details and so it was going
to be a lot easier for people to go out
and build their own houses and in fact
that has had the major advantage of there
being an incredibly low mortgage debt
level.
But it also has meant that that.
Part of the of the economy of
housebuilding has not existed.
And if you look at australian nation
national statistics you will see
that the building industry the home building
industry is a large percentage of the
overall economy. Well in nimbin.
That part of the economy has only been
one quarter of the size for this for the
purdah population.
It's only been a quarter of the size
because of people building their own home
that means that the whole other economics
of the area are also slowed down
and it also means that all of those people
that would normally have
experience in doing business.
Building houses have not had that
experience. So it. It's really.
I just i still think the easiest way for
nimbin in the future would be to take it
on consciously into a mat
learning how to create businesses
consciously
and i mean in a fairly open information
system where people throughout the whole
community can know what the
business is doing in economic terms
and how
and seeing the actual business
is growing in overall turnover
and seeing how much
more they're producing.
So
that then the whole community could have
a sense of a level of economic growth.
And could actually have its own figures
and to cystic so i think it comes down
to a question where you remain poor
if you think your poor and
if you start to decide
that you're not really very poor
and you can actually justify what you're
doing then you can change your economic
status from poor to well off
simply from a change of attitude.
You talk about.
Yeah.
You know i don't think it should
make itself part of the system
but i think it should stop pretending
that the system doesn't exist except
when it wants something off it.
I mean the fact that new guinea
exists or indonesia exists.
If you recognize it exists that doesn't
mean that you have to be part of it
but you do have to
recognise it's legitimate.
See in its own place and you have to be
able to compare yourself against it.
And likewise niman could
have its own currency but
that currency would have to be real against
the australian dollar you can have its
own economy but that economy has to be
real against the australian economy.
I just read the other day
that deca in bangladesh
has 1 6 16 per cent one
sixth of its total economic
work is on rickshaws
and they don't call them rickshaws but
that the whole the whole wheeling
of people by human effort
on the back of two wheeled carts is
one sixth of the total workforce
of decker's job.
Either in building them repairing them
or doing the wheeling now that's
economically real inside dhaka.
But it's not a very wise use of labour.
And likewise in nim and.
The question you don't have to be be
part of the system in order to realize
that economics does actually exist
and even if no one talks about it then
every day of the week a certain number of
people are going to be
building some houses
and some other people are
going to be doing this
and some people are
going to be doing that.
I mean you've only got a limited
number of people in any one valley
and they are only going to do a
certain amount of work each week
and some more we do. More and
that that amount can lift
and drop depending on how they feel.
But as soon as you start talking
about what people are doing
and whether people are getting
themselves poorer or richer.
Then you're talking about. Economics.
Probably right. Lost. I mean. I think.
Well. I think you know.
It's a time of their elected not a lot
of ways in which they live. The way.
You know except if you look at include
one extra factor in there of whether
they feel that they are poor or well off
when you look at a ton of all fours
that some really interesting examples
and comparisons that you can make.
And one of the factors of value
that i think you have to take into
it is is a person free to move.
It's all very well to
have a beautiful house
and lots of really beautiful
things about the place.
It's the environment is spectacular
and the lifestyle can be very enjoyable
if you think you got the right to leave
even heaven can be a terrible
place if you feel trapped there.
Now with tana well there's
because of the headspace
there is a poverty a poverty back here
that holds people in there when
they may not want to be there.
The comparison is really easy and with
another place in the district court.
Bill includes which was started.
10 years after tournament was just had
its 10 year anniversary a few weeks ago.
And a billion cliffs.
Which is the second biggest community
around here after town of all fours.
People who joined it 10 years ago the
first people paid $4000 for a share
and i think it ranged from four
up to about eight nine thousand.
Those people are now the minimum amount
that if they wish to leave their empty
block of land is now worth twenty two
thousand dollars. Empty
and that's the minimum.
So they're for their for what they've
put in they don't feel trapped
and in the sense
that they have to stay there because
they can't afford to go anywhere else.
Whereas at the same time
i know of one situation.
A friend of mine where he if he sold his
house and land a ton of all fours.
He would only be getting something
in the 20s with the house as well.
There's no in fact
that the house whose house it at
all is far more beautiful than.
Lots of thing places are doing cliffs.
But because of the structure
and the head space tenable
force thinks it's poor
and therefore people who.
Are thinking of coming in are only
willing to pay small amounts of money.
Now that means that someone
who is there a ton of oil.
It's not actually worth their while to sell
because for what they'll get they won't
be able to go very far in
terms. As of any other house.
If they sell they will be have
to use their money just for.
Living in the period of time
before they have anything else
that means a person isn't free to move.
Now what's the whole lesson that's
been going on out of east europe
and russia but that people felt
that they weren't free to move
and now if they try to move.
They're not free to movie there
because germany and france
and all those countries know how many
people would like to move at least very
economic reasons and they don't want that
many slaves coming into western europe.
But the sense of being not free to move
is not just a question of physical
restrictions.
It's also largely an economic
question is your theory.
Not. Not having.
Yes. And not not having learnt.
Yeah. Yeah i realize that you.
I suppose part of
that poverty headspace
is a whole suggestion
that money is inherently evil that.
Worrying about it or
making it or getting it.